roasted vegetables are one of the most
essential side dishes that every new
cook should have in their arsenal
they're easy versatile and the perfect
addition to any meal here's how to make
them perfectly every time first up we're
gonna prep our vegetables we're gonna
cut them down so they can all resemble
the same sizes this way it will have
more surface area that means they'll
have more contact with the pan it's
important to group vegetables by their
families so start your vegetables like
butternut squash potatoes and beets are
gonna take a longer time to cook but
cruciferous vegetables like Brussels
sprouts and cauliflower are gonna take
less time to cook
long story short that done stir the
vegetable the long girl take to cook
olive oil is also key to spreading the
heat more evenly all over your veggies
that way they'll get nice and charred so
now for seasoning we're gonna start with
dried herbs dried herbs can withstand
very long times in the oven and they
won't burn and the fun thing about
spices is that you can mix it up you can
choose anything that you'd like right
now we're gonna try paprika and garlic
powder but honestly you can do chili
powder cumin onion powder or you can
just keep it super simple which is salt
and pepper the sky is the limit now
we're ready to roast you want to roast
some at a high temperature like 425
because this is going to give them that
crunchy outside and that's soft inside
we're looking for start your vegetables
are going to take about 25 to 30 minutes
and your cruciferous vegetables about 15
to 20 halfway to roasting you're going
to want to take them out and give them a
good stir so they can cook and char
evenly when they're done they should be
fork tender and have a nice charred
caramelized outside we're going to add
some fresh parsley on this cauliflower
just to give it a pop of flavor and now
we're ready to serve there's so many
ways to enjoy these veggies you can eat
them as a side dish with your favorite
protein add them to tacos or let them be
the star of the show and enjoy them over
your favorite cream with some pesto when
done correctly roasted vegetables are
one of the simplest yet impressive
dishes that will Wow at any dinner party
or can be whipped up for an easy
weeknight dinner learn how to fit them
perfectly now and they'll reward you
time and time again oh yes
[Music]
[Music]